So I was thinking of talking to you more
about sampling, but it seems like it might work out
best to just have some hands on experience with it
so we're going to put those things on the homework. So
given that we're actually in a position now to, to
kind of wrap up the whole Bayes net inference piece
that we were talking about. So do you want to help
remind me, Charles, what were the things that we covered?
>> Sure, I can help you with that. We covered Bayesian Inference [LAUGH]
I'm sorry.
I'm punch drunk.
>> I'm going to choose not to pay attention to that. Instead, write
Bayesian Networks. We talked about the
Bayesian Network representation of joint probability distributions.
>> Right. We did a lot of examples of how to actually do inference with networks.
You know, exactly how do we, do we
compute probabilities of particular values. We mentioned sampling.
>> That's right.
>> And then we did a Naive Bayes.
>> Well first we did say that, that in general it's hard
to do exact inference. It's actually hard to do even approximate inference.
>> Mm-hm.
>> But we talked about a special
case of bayesian networks, that was called naive
bayes with the naive part being, that we're
assuming that attributes are independent of one another.
>> Condition on the label.
>> Right. And this was actually helping us make a
link between all this bayesian stuff. The bayesian rabbit hole we
went down. And classification, which is the core machine learning
topic that we've been spending a lot of time on.
>> So the other thing that I really
liked about this notion, this link to classification, Michael,
is that when I was talking about Bayesian
learning, what we ended up with at the end
is this nice idea that we had a gold standard, right? We had a sort of way
of talking about what the right hypothesis was
and, ultimately, what the right classification was by computing
these probabilities. And sometimes, we couldn't do it because, typically,
you can't actually do the for loop that requires you compute
conditional probabilities of hypothesis given data. Over say an infinite number
of hypothesis, but at least we kind of knew what the
right thing was and we made right assumptions we could do
things like derive, oh I don't know, a sum of squared
errors or various other things that you might do and that
was all very cool. But what you've done here when you
do inference. Is at least with a Naive Bayes case,
you've shown us a way that we can do classification
using these things, that actually is tractable, and is the
right thing to do under certain assumptions. I really like
that. And the other thing that I think is worth
mentioning is that not only does it link this Bayesian
learning to classification. But it connects classification back to this
general notion of Bayesian learning, Bayesian inference where, you don't
have to worry about just figuring out the most likely label
given a bunch of attributes. But because it's a Bayes network and
you can compute anything from it, you could try to ask
well what's the likelihood that I see some particular attribute or set
of attributes, given a label or given a subset of attributes
on all those kind of things that you could do. With the
Bayesian learning. So inference gives us this power to not just
do classification, but to do a larger set of things beyond classification.
I think that's kind of cool.
>> Cool. Yeah, well said. The, the For, and another thing,
kind of in that same space is that it handles missing attributes
really well. So whereas things like, oh. You know, decision trees
and so forth, if you give me an example that doesn't have
one of the attribute values and you've hit that part of
the decision tree where you need to know that attribute value you're
stuck. Whereas in this naive base setting, you can still do the
probabalistic inference over the missing attributes
because all the things are linked
by probabilities.
>> Nice.
>> All right. So I think, you know, you'll, you'll get
a much stronger handle of this when you go through the,
the homework problems. But I think that's enough for Bayesian inference.
And I think that actually wraps up classification and regression more generally.
>> Right. So we're done with supervised learning. Well, one's never done with
supervised learning. But we're at least done with this part of the course.
>> Because there's always more to supervise learn.
>> That's right. And in particular you'll get
a nice example of this, because you'll be taking an exam.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And your input will be the exam, and then we'll give you a label back.
>> [LAUGH] I guess that's one way to think about it.
>> Well and then they'll get to generalize beyond
that for the next time they take the exam.
>> Very good! All right. Well, well thanks
very much, this has been fun. Thanks Charles.
>> This has been fun. I will see you in the second mini course.
>> All right.
>> Bye.